after years of speculation one of the
great Mysteries of the art world has
finally been resolved we now know who
bought Hunter Biden's Doodles according
to the news Outlet Insider Hunter's
buyers include major Democrat donors can
you believe it one such donor is a woman
named Elizabeth Hirsch naftali she has
given a bunch of money to Joe Biden's
campaign and to the Democrat National
Campaign Committee she's hosted
fundraisers with Kamala Harris she is a
Democrat muckety muck and what do you
know
right around the time that naphtali
bought some of Hunter's art Hunter's
father the president named her to a
prestigious political commission the
commission for the preservation of
America's Heritage abroad
and naftali is just one of the buyers
another buyer whose identity remains
unknown apparently spent 875 thousand
dollars on Hunter's scribbles all in all
Hunter's art show generated 1.3 million
dollars in sales and who knows how many
presidential appointments
it's a big rift of course we all knew
that Hunter's art is terrible and his
only notable accomplishments are petty
crime so the only reason anyone could
possibly have for buying his junk is to
Curry favor with his dad
it's just a plain old bribe and yet
more evidence of high crimes and
misdemeanors all of which add up to an
increasingly plain fact it is time for
Republicans to impeach Joe Biden I'm
Michael Knowles as the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Snow White
the new Snow White she's not
White
it's not more of a Dusky color a little
bit swarthier I say this is a member of
the swarthy community and she
the the not being Typecast is the least
of it she just gave an interview in
which she has persuaded me that I think
at most seven people are gonna go see
this movie we will get into why what
Disney is doing is so bad and stupid
first though major movement in
geopolitics and major movement with the
leaders of Nations and coincidentally
one of those big movements is right here
in Hungary so this week I'm in Hungary I
am now officially a Hungarian author my
best-selling blank book reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guy has
been translated into Hungarian and it's
been released it was released yesterday
and so I'm on the ground in Hungary I'm
doing my book tour here and I will cap
that off with a speech at the MCC which
is one of the big think tanks at the MCC
Fest a big political event here in
Hungary that will be on Friday uh past
American speakers include our friends
Dennis Prager and Tucker Carlson and I
will I will hopefully follow follow
their acts as the the US and the West
broadly are looking at the prospect of
World War III which the Hungarian
president
just brought up uh yesterday in
Transylvania so we'll get to that in one
second first though I want to get to our
political leader Joe Biden and I want to
get to this point that I have held off
on for a long time you can't say that
I've been rushing toward this or I've
been hyperbolic or anything like that I
have always been pushing the brakes on a
purely politicized impeachment now is
the time to impeach the legal predicate
is there I don't think impeachment is
just a political act and I think it's
just when the opposition party gets the
house then we impeach the guy who's in
the white house that's not how it's
supposed to work there's a legal basis
for it Biden meets that basis the
evidence of the bribes and the high
crimes and misdemeanors it's so apparent
now we have terabytes and terabytes of
his son's laptop proving this
certainly showing a lot of evidence for
it so that the time has come and I'm not
the only one saying it and Lauren bobert
is not the only one saying it and Jim
Banks and House Representatives they're
not the only ones saying it Kevin
McCarthy as well speaker of the house is
floating the prospect of impeaching
Biden
rising to the level of impeachment
inquiry which provides Congress the
strongest power to get the rest of the
knowledge and information needed because
this president has also used something
we have not seen since Richard Nixon use
the weaponization of government to
benefit his family and deny Congress the
ability to have the oversight I believe
we will follow this all the way to the
end and this is going to rise to an
impeachment inquiry the way the
Constitution tells us to do this and we
have to get the answers to these
questions
the only part I don't like there is the
Nixon dunking okay we need to we need to
stop knocking Richard Nixon Richard
Nixon he made some political mistakes as
president and some of his policies were
kind of wrong-headed but Richard Nixon
got done wrong he was the first
conservative the first Republican to get
done in by the Deep State while he was
in the white house it was the test run
for what happened to Trump Richard Nixon
is a far better man than any of the
Democrat presidents in my lifetime the
reason the libs hate him so much the
reason that the Deep State hated him so
much is because Richard Nixon was right
about Alger Hiss and Richard Nixon when
he was up on Capitol Hill pointed out
that there were Communists in the
government working for the state
department including a top state
department official a top lib named
Alger Hiss who was instrumental in the
founding of the UN and everyone called
Nixon crazy and they attacked him and he
held firm and he was right Al Jaris was
a dirty rotten freaking commie and we
proved it they never forgave him for it
and so the Deep State threw him out of
office for some complete Elite nonsense
tape on a door for some campaign dirty
trick that the Democrats have played
every campaign 10 times whatever the
Republicans have done so okay that's a
little bit of a digression I get I get
very defensive of my tricky Dicky but
but beyond that what do we mean that
Richard Nixon we haven't seen the
weaponization of government like this
since Richard Nixon what about Barack
Obama who weaponized the IRS against his
political opponents against a group that
I was a member of the friends of Abe the
conservatives who were in Show Business
in Hollywood and New York Barack Obama
wielded the government agencies against
his political enemies all the time this
has been a pattern that we've seen on
the left and it's been done on the left
way more than it's been done on the
right and that's not even the reason
that this meets the the standard for
impeachment we've got evidence of
corruption we've got evidence of of
bribery we've got evidence of high
crimes and misdemeanors why not why not
impeach him because we're gonna
ruin people's trust in our institutions
I'm pretty sure that ship sailed guys
well because if we do it to them they'll
do a test they've impeached Trump what
like a hundred times already and they're
going to keep doing it if he gets it
back into office the time has come why
because that means we'll get Kamala
Harris we're heading into a presidential
election who cares the time has come
folks the time has also come for you to
check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days away
from the Durbin Accords the greatest
threat to the US Dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend on text Knowles right now
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to 98.98 98
so of course right when the Republicans
are on the brink of actually doing
something right when they are on the
brink of wielding their political power
to impeach the president to maybe try to
rest some power back from the Liberals
they're going to distract us with a
bunch of flying saucers of course of
course we need a distraction so now the
house
is going to hold urgent hearings
on UFOs they're here Capitol Hill braces
for the UFO Invasion with an epic house
Committee hearing that's right we got it
baby we're getting the UFOs over here
I have one question I have one question
about the UFOs forget I'm going to put
aside I know Matt Walsh and I have an
ongoing debate where I point out that
extraterrestrial aliens don't exist and
Matt says a bunch of nonsense I'm not
even having that debate right now I'm
just all I'm asking is this question
how come China doesn't have hearings on
UFOs
how come Russia doesn't have urgent
hearings
urgent meetings of the senior leadership
about all the extraterrestrials E.T
coming to planet Earth how come if you
look at a map of all the UFO sightings
around the world how come I'm not saying
all of them are in the west in the
United States and Europe and how come
the vast majority of them are
foreign
what's that about
is this really an urgent thing do you
really believe
if you really seriously believe
that
Little Green Men
are the most or even a remotely urgent
problem facing our nation or do you
think it is bread and circuses
distraction
perhaps sincere
fantasy but perhaps cynical distraction
nonsense which do you think is more
likely seems pretty clear to me but hey
hey former Pentagon officials Former
Intelligence Agency people they swear up
and down that we in the United States
were in possession of Technology from
outer space
the objective here I think and the
opportunity is for the American people
to come to better understand why it is
that so many in Congress actually take
seriously the idea that there are UFOs
UAP that are violating U.S airspace and
the associated rumor allegation that we
may have in our possession
off-world technology recovered from
someone else's Space Program I've been
told that we have recovered technology
that did not originate on this Earth
by officials in the Department of
Defense and by former intelligence
officials
notice it's always I've been told by
very credible Anonymous people I listen
One Time One seriously you're not going
to believe this my my mother's cousin's
best friend from work her boss
Z's nephew worked at a defense
contractor and he talked to the janitor
who once overheard some kind of
anonymous guys talking about how there
were definitely UFOs
yeah and you can take that to the bank
uh-huh
so that's why we need to have these
hearings we need to have these hearings
so that the American people can
understand why members of Congress
might believe in extraterrestrial aliens
I'm not speaking ill of members of
Congress I like a great many members of
Congress some of my dear friends are
members of Congress
there were members of Congress who
believe all sorts of things that are not
true
not rational there's a member of
Congress who once in a in a public
hearing
asked if putting too many people on the
island of Guam would cause the island to
capsize
okay the fact that a handful of kooky
congressmen
think that E.T is out there trying to
make contact with us that doesn't
convince me
the fact that Anonymous deep Staters
Anonymous people whose job it is to
conduct psyops are anonymously telling
us that there are little green men out
there I just
I just don't believe it
think about how the quality of cameras
has improved in the last forget the last
50 years in the last five years in the
last two years the quality of the camera
on your iPhone could shoot in a super
duper ultra high definition feature film
and yet the quality of footage of UFOs
has remained exactly the same since
1945. there has been no improvement with
it's always
for some reason when the cameras no
matter how advanced they are encounter
aliens or Bigfoot the footage gets
really grainy I don't know why that is
it's really strange
just don't believe it folks why would
the government be putting this out there
though I guess we have to address that
question well
few reasons
uh one it could be our technology and
we're trying to be cagey about it two it
could be the technology of an adversary
I don't really believe that I don't
think that China for instance has
technology much more advanced than ours
not yet at least that's an issue that
we'll get to in a second uh it could be
that actually we've depleted a lot of
our our defense infrastructure and as
China is rising so quickly it could be
that we're trying to Bluff I think it
was Darren Beatty who made this point he
said that he thinks that the Pentagon in
the Deep state are just trying to Bluff
and convince China that we're in
possession of ET technology
it's a little bit outlandish but it's
not as outlandish as Little Green Men
coming to Earth
the evidence for which is nil it's zero
it's just the media how do we know that
there are little green men because the
media tell you so and because Anonymous
people at the Pentagon and Shady figures
in the the intelligence agencies tell
you so the the people who love AI all
the time whose job it is to lie are the
ones who have convinced you that this is
likely uh doesn't seem very likely to me
seems like a nice distraction huh what
who are we going to impeach what were we
going to do about immigration oh is that
what happened what about the failing
economy oh look a butterfly that's not a
butterfly that's a flying saucer now
speaking of entertainment
we covered woke Snow White no longer
white snow taupe snow beige snow swarthy
snow not well Snow's nuts worthy I don't
some kind of sediment or sand that is no
longer
Blanc uh the the new reboot of Snow
White is going to have a Hispanic lady
and
that's bad enough because it contradicts
the story and it does so for purely
leftist political reasons but
this girl this young woman just
explained the far more egregious changes
to the story than the casting of this
this out of place actress
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that it longer 1937
we abs we ABS he wrote a snow white that
is
not going to be safe for The Prince and
she's not gonna be dreaming about true
love she's dreaming about becoming the
leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in Snow White is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign
how many dozens of people do you think
are going to go see that
maybe I'm being too optimistic how many
how many couple of people do you think
are going to see that movie that sounds
so
so terrible
the the central feature of the movie
forget about the central feature of Snow
White's character namely that she's very
very white it's in her name
forget that actually seriously forget
that for a second this is the central
feature of the movie is that it's a
movie about love and that she is
reawoken but by love
and they're taking the love out of it no
it's not about Prince Charming and love
anymore it's about what a girl boss she
is because that's what little girls
dream of they dream of being a girl boss
so insist
so insist the Liberals but that's not
what little girls dream of ever and it's
going to flop just like the all the
other ones flop and the left Bears a lot
of responsibility for this because the
left controls Disney and all of the
other institutions in the country but
the right there is some responsibility
to because the right has gone along with
this
the right has gone along with this kind
of language that
undermines
love that that undermines the family as
the basic unit of society that
undermines traditional gender roles that
undermines traditional Duty period
the right is going along with it because
while while for decades the right would
would pay some lip service to
traditional Family Values what would
they say to the other side of their
mouths they'd say we that's why we need
creative destruction and we need to
innovate constantly and we need everyone
to go to work for goodness sakes
president Trump whom I love he's my
favorite President of my lifetime but
president Trump bragged about how low
the women's unemployment rate is which
sounds nice until you think about it
what does that mean
he's bragging about how women are just
going out and laboring in that widget
Factory no they're not staying home with
their kids no siree that would be
retrograde no those women are going out
there and working in the factory like
they damn well should
who needs a homemaker who needs a mommy
at home no sir we're conservatives why
would we support that so we bear a
little responsibility to even the
conservatives even the greatest
president in my lifetime we have gone
along with this we've embraced a kind of
feminism we've embraced a kind of a more
than a kind of individualism
we've embraced a kind of social
radicalism some conservatives even want
to want to be the progressives
we want to say no we're more Progressive
than the Democrats are now well that's
how you end up
seeding all of the institutions to the
left that's how you end up with snow
taupe bragging about how there's not
going to be any more love in a fairy
tale it's not going to be any more love
in one of the most cherished Beautiful
Stories in the American Cinema now
speaking of women's issues
if you think that's bad you think it's
bad that feminists are running Hollywood
just wait until you find out that
apparently because of our far left
Administration girl bosses are going to
be running our military what could go
wrong what could go wrong you know when
I when I think about all that I admire
in women there are a lot of things that
I admire and we're not in feminists but
in women like real nice women you know
how nurturing they are how empathetic
they are how uh organized they are how
they can multitask and one thing I
really admire is how good they look well
when you want to look good
you got to check out genu cell right now
head on over to geniusell.com Knowles
our friends of Virginia sell sold out of
their Dark Spot Corrector and our
listeners have been begging begging like
dogs on their knees for a restock well
I've got great news just in time for the
summer it's back in stock geniusell's
famous Dark Spot Corrector has not won
but three Cutting Edge ingredients goes
to work fast to Target sunspots dark
spots liver spots even old discoloration
both on your face and your hands you can
now enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
Junior sells most popular package also
features their summer Essentials like
their best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed at how quickly you see
results or you get 100 of your money
back guaranteed I love the owner of this
company Coptic Christian from Egypt left
for the American dream head on over to
genucel.com Knowles right now get the
Dark Spot Corrector in the genius Hall
most popular package geniusell.com we'll
save over seventy seven zero percent all
orders include a mystery luxury gift ooh
while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles
the greatest interview show on the
internet many people are saying it yes
or no is more than just the most fun you
can have on YouTube it's also the best
way to get to know your favorite YouTube
Stars such as my friend
Frank Cooper does Brett think women
should drive
does Brett think Helen Keller was faking
it you will get those answers and so
much more in our episode check out this
tease
I admit I do sympathize a little with
Dylan Mulvaney because I too was once an
impressionable theater kid and who knows
what could have happened to me if I was
cast into rent on Broadway in my wayward
youth I sympathize with don't know any
because I was a theater kid let's answer
and I'll one two three
[Music]
thank you
uh what a tease that's why you gotta
watch the whole episode The yes or no
game by the way the the board game is
back in stock you go to dailywire.com
shop to get your game today these games
go fast yes or no is hands down the best
way to delve into the most
thought-provoking topics of our time
with your friends and family go to
dailyword.com shop order yes or no today
Joe Biden
is apparently picking
the first woman ever to serve on the
Joint Chiefs of Staff
and why is he picking her because she's
a woman
is he picking her because she's the most
qualified for the job no is he picking
her because she was the number one
person recommended for the job no he's
picking her because she's a woman and of
course a woman should run the military
right
right traditionally women always run the
military because they're so much
physically stronger than men
and because there's so much colder and
more calculating and and able to deal
with blood and guts and Gore in death
and really difficult decisions of life
and death right that's why right is that
it I'm not so sure defense secretary
Lloyd Austin
presented Biden with a series of choices
for who would serve as the Navy's Next
Top officer
and he picked a dude an admiral Samuel
paparo Who currently leads the U.S uh
Pacific Fleet
uh he was he was supposed to succeed
the and become the next chief of Naval
operations and Biden decided no he was
going to pick this lady I have no knock
on the lady I seriously I don't I don't
mean to knock her personally I'm very
grateful for her service I admire her
service it's a wonderful thing to do
ladies should not be running the
military
they they just shouldn't
do you really believe even we have
leftists who listen to this show
and who write into me sometimes we have
leftists we have feminists we have all
sorts of people I appreciate that and I
think and what some of you have told me
as you listen to the show because I
don't just give the GOP talking points
that I spend probably just about as much
time going after conservatives as I do
going after the left so I'm I'm speaking
to you now I'm not only speaking to the
conservatives I'm speaking even to you
hardened feminist leftist listeners
you really think a lady should be
running the military you really if
you're being totally you don't need to
admit this to anyone publicly you really
think that
you do not
men are
soldiers men are killers men are
physically tougher men that's a job for
a man
right
yes we can admit that but you'll say
this lady she deserves it no she
obviously doesn't deserve it she wasn't
recommended for the job
Joe Biden just picked her because she's
a woman
so you can't even say well you're right
generally men should are better at
running the military than women but you
know in this case no she she was just
picked for being a woman
well but it's important that we pick her
why why is it important because this
breaks the glass ceiling and this shows
that women can do anything yeah well
women women can be appointed to any
position by liberal presidents of course
what's the point of the military
is the point of the military to make
feminists feel good about themselves
is the point of the military to present
some radical and absurd notion that the
Sexes are indiscernible rather than
complementary is that the point no the
point of the military is to kill our
enemies okay and as we have allowed at
the military along with all of our other
institutions to fall into Mission drift
and Mission creep the position of the
United States as the global hegemon has
fallen into doubt and our enemies have
risen up to the point that now you have
world leaders around the globe and
especially in the west and actually in
the country that I'm sitting in right
now Victor Orban who is probably the
last man in Europe the last person
standing up for traditional
Conservative Christian Western beliefs
that guy is now saying because the U.S
has allowed itself to be weakened so
much we are in a very perilous moment
and we are on the brink potentially of
War
why is it good why is it good to have a
woman leading the military it's not good
for the military not good for the
country I guess it's good for feminism
but feminism is bad for the country too
you heard this whole argument some some
years ago not all that long ago with
women in combat why is it good for women
to be in combat I think it's a National
Disgrace that we send women into combat
maybe some woman wants to do it too bad
the military is not about your personal
desires it's about Fitness and about
killing our enemies okay and what we've
been doing is putting the cart before
the horse and this has been the disease
of our politics we do it in
pretty much every institution we do it
in Hollywood
we we put some stupid woke message in
ahead of entertainment that's why people
don't generally see the movies anymore
other than Barbie and Oppenheimer when
was the last time anyone talked about
the movies was very long time ago
we do it in the universities where we
just promote people and admit people not
based on whether they can handle the
course load but whether it will make us
feel good about our Multicultural
priorities and and wokeness and
political correctness okay well then the
standards Decline and then
and then our Elite no longer really
knows anything
it's a it's a big problem and this this
just came out
I fly into Hungary I'm not taking credit
for this but I fly into Hungary and
Victor Orban just comes out strong
against further funding the Ukraine war
and Victoria Bond gives this great
speech in Transylvania presumably
alongside Count Dracula and count
chocula and but Victor Victor Bond
they're the leader of Hungary gives this
speech and he says guys you have you you
were sleepwalking into World War III
because all you leaders in the west are
are living in Fantasyland he had a
wonderful line in this speech I
encourage you to go listen to the whole
speech or read it so you can read the
English translation in one he says that
if you're in European politics right now
if you mention Western values the only
values you're allowed to talk about are
mass migration
LGBT what was the other one let's see
hold on I'll just look it up I have a
computer here when I'm on the road it
says Mass migration LGBT oh and War
that's the only that's the third one
and but then he comes to a more
important point he says ladies and
gentlemen Dear Summer Camp the situation
we're living in today uh in which day by
day we are moving toward conflict the
question the million dollar question is
whether this conflict can be avoided
there are ever more studies and books on
this and I'm also working from them one
notable work says that in the last 300
years there have been 16 occasions when
a new champion
Global power has risen to pull alongside
or overtake the world's leading power
the bad news is that of the 16 instances
thus identified 12 have ended in war and
only four were peacefully resolved in
other words dear friends we are at the
most dangerous moment in World politics
today when the leading great power of
the United States
sees itself sinking towards second place
experience shows that the dominant great
power tends to see itself as more
benevolent and better intentioned than
it really is and attributes malice to
its Challenger more often than is or
should be justified of course
human nature consequently the starting
point for each opposing party is not the
intentions of the counterpart but its
capabilities not what the counterpart
wants to do but what it is capable of
doing and thus war is already in the
making
this is what is called the thucydides
Trap named after the man who wrote the
history of the Peloponnesian War Between
Spartan Athens and who first identified
the problem and without going too much
into the thucydidity strap and all sorts
of international relations gobbledygook
there is an even odd or perhaps
providential coincidence here which is
that I was joking that I've now got the
Hungarian translation of my blank book
well the epitaph
of my blank book
is a quote from thucydides it's a quote
from the Peloponnesian War which says
that this is not an essay to win the
Applause at the moment but an enduring
work for all time
and that is the work in which
thucydides observes this problem of of a
rising power and uh clashing with the
dominant power and and it's a problem
that Victor rabban sees and and we can
deny it we can bury our heads in the
sand we can continue to turn away from
the beliefs that made us great we can
continue to focus on complete and utter
nonsense like LGBT ISM and flooding our
country with foreigners and uh funding
Wars all around the world
but that is not going to help us remain
in our dominant position
so long as we are putting the card
before the horse and refusing to do the
things that make us strong and great
that's very dangerous I had this thought
when I was traveling which is that uh I
I flew into Paris I had a layover in
Paris and I flew to to Hungary and I was
walking around and I speak a little
touch of French you know this if you
remember for the member room segmentum
you know I'll occasionally uh fall into
a little bit of French
but my fresh is really terrible I don't
speak a lot of French at all so I
thought okay I could try to speak a
little bit of French while I'm in the
airport but I don't really have to you
know why because I'm American and we're
the dominant power and everyone just
does whatever we want
and and every time I've had the
privilege of traveling in the last 20
years I've had that thought in the
Middle East in Europe in South Asia I
get to I get to do
what whatever I want and people are just
expected to speak English and that's
wild that's because we're the dominant
power and that is slipping and maybe
it's not irreversible
maybe we could turn this thing around
but you've got to address that problem
and we're not doing it we're not doing
it we're just being poisoned by leftism
you want to talk about leftism
and Leadership
really really sad story out of Canada
out of America's top hat
is a Toronto principle who was harassed
by the libs and called a racist for no
reason in late April of 2021 this
principle was brought to attend a
training a Dei diversity Equity
inclusion training by Kiki oh Joe
Thompson who's some huckster or race
Hustler who presented a lecture to
Toronto Public School administrators and
told them how virulent the racism was
that Afflicted Canadian society and said
that Canada was a Bastion of white
supremacy and colonialism and that the
horrors that were Unleashed by
colonialism and white white supremacism
and capitalism and sexism and this isn't
in thatism regularly destroyed the lives
of non-white and women Canadians okay so
this guy Richard bilzo
is just stood up and said no you know I
don't really agree with that and uh I I
he said I think that teaching people
this does an incredible disservice uh to
our our Learners and so what happened
after this was this race Hustler Kiki oh
Joe Thompson made a big uh
example out of this poor guy attacked
him he was just attacked by all these
Libs he was defamed he actually won a
court case because of how brutally he
was defamed but it didn't matter in the
long and short of it is very sadly
this guy killed himself
and he killed himself the family
released a statement
and they said he killed himself because
of the the stress and the the
reputational harm that was brought on by
him being smeared by the left in a
coordinated attack to be called a racist
when when he knew that he was not
I bring this up you know we obviously
can pray for this guy's soul and pray
for his family and everything I bring
this up though not just as a cautionary
Tale
for uh
for what's going on in our politics
broadly I mean it is a cautionary tale
for you for people who
mostly just live in private life you
know you're not running for office or
something like that and so you're living
in private life and sometimes even in
mostly private life
you find yourself the
object of the cancel mod and you will be
called if you're going to be canceled
you will be called racist because in the
West
racist is the worst thing that you can
possibly
be called and there's there's a lesson
to be learned from this tragedy and
you've got to learn it or
when God forbid that that mob turns on
you
you could wind up in a in a similarly
dark place we'll get to that in one
second first though we know that men and
women are undeniably different
not just physically but on a much deeper
level ironically the more the libs try
to erase these differences the more
pronounced the differences become for
example women are more nurturing than
men as we've said that's a fact holding
on to those facts and understanding them
is essential that is at the heart of
Dennis prager's new episode of prageru's
master's program
in this series Dennis is sharing 40
years worth of hard-earned wisdom as he
explores all kinds of topics such as
how to be a good person hurdles to
happiness the case for marriage this
newest episode is extremely important
because the more men and women
understand each other the more they will
be able to accept and appreciate their
unique differences this is a fun episode
you don't want to miss it go to
dailywire.com become a member and watch
prageru's Masters program
today
the lesson to take away here from the
sad case of the Toronto principal who
was smeared as a racist and defamed and
became so depressed
that he killed himself is
he believed it
he made one crucial mistake
he took it seriously
he thought that when the libs
were calling him a racist
they were sincere
or they cared about whether that
accusation was true or false
or that he thought that that was an
accusation that is even made in Earnest
today it's not it's completely
meaningless Ann Coulter told me this
when I was a college student it really
stuck with me the moment the left calls
you a racist you know you've won the
argument the moment the left calls you a
racist you should dance for joy you
should dance for joy because it means
you're a threat to them and it means
you've said something that they feel is
undermining their absurd political
program you should you should put that
on a plaque and frame it and put it on
your wall
you shouldn't do anything unjust
but assuming you're in this guy's
position you know you haven't done
anything on just you've you've examined
your conscience
I'm going through yourself I'm not I
don't think I'm not a racist then not
only forget about it smile oh you called
me a racist okay thanks I guess I'm
doing something right I guess I'm doing
something right Libs if I can get you to
try to smear me man I guess I'm right
over the target
it isn't real and I know that the right
has broadly woken up to this there were
still some really nice well-meaning
people who they still don't get it they
still
they they try to persuade the left no
I'm not racist actually you know I'm not
some of my very best friends are in
it's like the scene that I keep going
back to a Breaking Bad when the gangster
is about to kill Hank's brother-in-law
the cop
this is no Hank tell him you won't do
anything tell him you're sorry tell him
this to me it doesn't matter what I tell
him the guy made up his mind 10 minutes
ago they made up their mind they it drew
makes this point beautifully
sometimes people will call someone a
racial slur because they don't like the
race
much more often when someone calls
someone else a racial slur
it has nothing to do with whether that
person likes a race or not
it's just that the person doesn't like
the person he's insulting and so because
he doesn't like that person he's going
to use any attack he can to insult that
person
if you go up let's use a not a totally
politically charged one and I'm here in
Eastern Europe anyway if you go up to
someone you say you dumb stupid Pollock
is that indicative of a deep-seated
hatred of the Polish people
999 times out of a thousand no it just
means I don't like this person I'm gonna
I'm gonna use a naughty word that's it
now
speaking of
leadership
we got to get to the race the race is
really 2024 race I don't want to talk
about it too much every day because
we're still in silly season but I do
want to follow it because this is one of
the most interesting primary races in my
lifetime it's the most interesting
primary race
the only other one that might be as
interesting is 2016 because Trump came
out of nowhere
this one's actually more interesting
because we haven't seen a primary like
this since 1888 we haven't seen a
primary like this since Grover Cleveland
ran for a non-consecutive term the only
President American history to to win
non-consecutive terms so
the debate stage is set for now there
could still be a little bit of movement
so maybe you get one more candidate up
there but basically the stage is set
seven candidates make the debate
Trump obviously Ron DeSantis obviously
the vague ramaswamy surging now in not
only in the third place but on the heels
of second place on the heels of DeSantis
uh Mike Pence made it Nikki Haley made
it and Nikki Haley is important because
Nikki Haley has overtaken Ron DeSantis
in South Carolina so if DeSantis can't
make a big showing in Iowa and New
Hampshire and they get down to South
Carolina and he's not even in second
place there the DeSantis campaign is
probably done the fact that Nikki Haley
who a lot of people counted out the
moment she announced is surged into
second in South Carolina shows you it's
still a live race and that's that's good
news for every candidate including Ron
DeSantis I guess especially Ron DeSantis
right now who's seen his numbers drop in
recent days uh Tim Scott's going to make
the stage Chris Christie Chris's son's
happening baby let's go and they've all
made the stage
the problem for them
is
why would Trump show up
the reason Trump would show up is
because maybe the polls are tightening
and he'll look kind of weak or afraid or
cowardly if he doesn't show up but Trump
brings the ratings you and I might watch
the primary debate if Trump is not there
I guess I guess I'll probably watch it
or I'll watch most of it if Trump is
there I'll for sure watch it because you
know it'll be entertaining but but
forget about this if you're listening to
this show right now you are paying
closer attention to politics than 97 of
this country at least
what about the far greater number of
people
who are really only going to watch if
it's interesting and who think that this
is a snooze Fest otherwise I agree
with the people boosting certainly Vivek
the people boosting Tim Scott the people
boosting
even Mike Pence and certainly the people
boosting Ron DeSantis who say the the
gaps in these numbers don't matter until
they're face to face
but they've got to get Trump's numbers
down if they want him to get face to
face because right now Trump has
absolutely no reason to show up and and
before we go
it's a little
there's a little extra wild card in
there which is Glenn youngin's approval
rating is exploding right now Glenn
Young's approval rating in Virginia
Republican gov new Republican governor
of Virginia
is it 57 Virginia is a blue Commonwealth
how did he do it
is it because he's a total squish he's
not a total swish
he's not quite as right-wing as maybe
some of us are
but he's not a total squish don't forget
the successful parts of his campaign the
stuff that put him over the edge was
when Glenn youngin was running on
Hardcore cultural issues
bathrooms and schools on critical race
theory in schools
real serious cultural War issues
pulling 57 percent of Virginia
and Glenn young has thus far managed not
to irritate president kofe
in the way that koffe wants to murder
Ron DeSantis as of right now I've never
heard Donald Trump say one nasty thing
about Glenn yankin
so if Glenn young can wait in the wings
maybe soak up a little bit of adulation
maybe put himself in a place where he's
he's a favorite of trump for a cabinet
post a running mate perhaps or
that he is potentially
in the wings if DeSantis collapses and
Trump goes to prison
could be a very different race now with
all of that leadership we're going to be
looking around the broader Western
leadership as I Meander the streets of
Budapest if you're in town go pick up a
copy of my book is a very funny story on
that book by the way which I'll get to I
guess I'll have to get to it tomorrow in
the meantime if I don't see you on the
Danube
I'm Michael Knowles this is Michael Noel
show there will not be any member block
this week because it's just come on
we're in Eastern Europe all right
they've got they haven't built up the
kind of Interest structure for that they
haven't built up the kind of
infrastructure for the full-on claim de
lachem experience just yet and if we
fall into World War III they won't but
uh I will look forward to the member
block when I get back in the meantime
I'm Michael knows this is Michael see
you tomorrow
[Music]
oh